I actually think this bit of a problem
with what's on the board right now this
table and there's not very much on the
board right I think the problem is
calling these things what problems where
problem as if there's something
different from what you've been doing
for this entire topic they the same
thing they're just wearing different
clothes it's not like oh you know this
is this is me in school uniform and then
there's the school uniform me and then
there's pajamas made and there's party
you know who's the same person just
dressed up a different way and that's
exactly what these questions are like
okay so let's start going through to get
intimidated by all of the words let's
get down the important formation ring
with me
you're a tortilla disco it's you raised
by me eat chicken bought my students
raises five dollars pause five dollars
thank you
but not just five dollars there's lots
of dollars in this question I wanted
nerd one five those beads five dollars
each ticket like I said thank you five
dollars each to get let's keep going the
costs of running the disco total one
hundred and thirty dollars okay so I'm
going to write a hundred and thirty
dollars how would you like to describe
it yeah
total I'd say total cost total cost
because it's not like it's cost per
student interest that would be not a
very good way to raise money okay
and also what are you doing at this
disco anyway so five dollars each ticket
I didn't $1 for each costs okay
sorry fair but a total cost how many
tickets must be sold to make a profit of
$300 so I'm gonna write $300 then I'm
going to write profit and question mark
because that's what I'm aiming at that's
my target
then they give you a bit of a heads I
will just point out the fact that
nothing in the brackets which I'm about
to read out doesn't always appear
actually that's part of the skill of
this kind of question to go to take that
and make up your own names and own
pretty rules for whatever's in the
question right it says let n stand for
the number of tickets salsa and equals
number of tickets sold okay so now
what's important here is we're actually
going to add something onto this that
isn't stated explicitly in the question
but it's implied and if you have a
different color it will be handed this
if you don't it's okay
see these numbers here right these
numbers they're all dollars but what's
hidden in there is that they're not the
same dollars some dollars are coming in
for the fundraising and some are going
out right some immigrants a man okay now
look five dollars for each ticket is
that coming your tots are going up it's
coming in they're paying us right so to
indicate that I don't know you say plus
right this is good it's adding to the
amount of money that we have now you can
kind of see what's happening next right
that one hundred thirty dollars the cost
where's that money going it's going out
right I'm we're losing this money right
so it's going to get subtractive this
three hundred dollars is a profit its
profit so I want that to be a plus okay
you okay with that right now we're ready
to form our equation okay if it is the
number of tickets sold
then how much money will come in in
turtlenecks for instance if I solve ten
tickets how much actual money like what
dollar value will I get ten tickets 50
bucks in if I saw 100 tickets five
hundred dollars in is the hurt right so
what I'm doing is I'm taking the number
of tickets and I'm just multiplying it
by the cost of each ticket are you okay
with that so I'm gonna write down five
and if you like I'm going to say what
that is is
being come from tickets because $5.00 is
the income from one ticket then 5n is
the income from all of the tickets than
itself
now that's positive I could write a plus
there if I wanted to but I don't need
you okay I've got money coming in but I
also have money coming out so what am I
going to add to this equation I've got
to take away 130 okay now what we've got
here is on another pair of ideas which
I'll just give names to in a second I
get to question um this 5n right we
would call this gross income gross it's
like everything coming in okay but once
you take away some of the stuff that we
had to use we call it net income it's a
little bit like if you are you know if
you buy a bag of chips or like a can of
a can of tuna or something like that
right the cheater inside sorry the whole
mess of the whole thing that's the gross
weight and then what's inside the active
tuna that's the net way that's what's
left over after you take away the care
okay so that's what I've got so far do
you want ask a question okay you're
actually good to mix it whatever you
going on nevermind okay so five my
hundred thing now this will give me the
profit okay now just just predict for a
second what would happen if for instance
suppose our marketing campaign doesn't
do a very good job
and I don't sell any tickets there are
tickets that wouldn't be very good with
it right what would it mean for how much
I earn out at the end yeah good I'm um
as at thank you say I'd be in the Rif I
haven't made any money no in fact I've
lost money I'm in debt that kind of
sucked right but that's what happened if
n was zero okay yep well that's a great
question
you know this total cost what things
might go in there you might have to hire
a DJ have to get a venue often those
kinds of things you have to
before you've even sold any tickets cuz
you gotta get that organized like a head
so maybe we can but frequently you can't
I had that's the way events are for now
we don't need to really worry about that
let's just assume it's a cost I have no
idea let's move on you can give me an
idea by researching it after you finish
discretion okay
now that was just a hypothetical what do
I want the profits of it specifically I
want $300
I want that profit to be $300 are you
happy with that that's what I actually
bought so we're just gonna label that
that's the desired profit now I've got
my equation so now I can solve right now
I'm back look at this guy you see why I
say these are different problems it's
the same problem just dressed up
differently what I did it yeah okay I
want to get this 130 out of the way I'll
add it to both sides that leaves me with
five in on that side and on the
right-hand side I only need to do one
more thing to get in by itself to get
the cuvette tough William okay so I'm
gonna divide by 5 and divide by 5
okay and that's gonna tell you yep 86
very good okay now just check does that
seem a reasonable number yeah I think
that's in the ballpark okay and of
course what you could do is you can just
go back to this original and just crunch
through the process 86 times 5 that'll
give you a figure you take away $130
because that money is going out and you
should end up on your $300 profit okay
so when you have to go through these
other questions all the point out is see
how I remember I said there's brackets
are there and they give you a bit of a
hand they stop giving you a head okay so
you will start to have to work out what
do i what led to a tradition what's it
equal to it's not always so simple all
right off you go